[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
depend on me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
okay
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
will be gone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the song
[Music]
[Music]
pick up my
[Music]
[Music]
we don't get food again
[Music]
a change it had to come
we knew it all along and the world looks
just the same if history
ain't changed
[Music]
pick up my guitar and play
just like yesterday
then i'll get on my knees
[Music]
we don't get food again
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
i moved myself and my family aside
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
to
[Music]
[Music]
the right
[Music]
just like yesterday
[Music]
no
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
baby
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
meet the new boss
same as the whole boss
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's go back let's go back
[Music]
but it don't take too much time to see
what you're doing to me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
keep doing things
people walking around everyday
think about what you're trying to do
[Music]
please
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do you know
[Music]
just a little bit just a little bit
[Music]
wrong
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
just a little bit
[Music]
me
[Music]
is
[Music]
ftc
[Music]
[Music]
please
[Music]
too long i'm wondering if your love's
still strong
[Music]
[Music]
baby
then that time i went and said goodbye
now i'm back
hey here i am
[Music]
yeah i'm still delivered i'm young
i'm yours oh
that's why i know you're my only day
baby here i am
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
please welcome lordan official junior
things look
so bad everywhere
in this whole world what is fair
we walk the line and try to see
[Music]
it's good to be home orlando what's
poppin
[Music]
my name is lorden official but from now
through november 1st my first name is
lorden
make a plan to vote official
yeah i'm that official with it
right now i'm a senior at the university
of florida
and i'm lucky to be on a full
scholarship i'm lucky that i'm the vice
president of the student body
and i'm lucky that i'm the first person
in my family to attend
[Applause]
college
i'm a regular college student though i
like to watch anime
i like to listen to hip-hop and i love
to spend time with my friends
i love the life that i live i'm grateful
to everyone that has given me a hand
and supported me on my journey to get to
where i am here
but before i was a college student
before i was as lucky as i was
i was just a young boy from griffin park
housing projects
that's only about a 15-minute walk down
that way
i was born and raised in orlando and i
grew up right here
in the parramore neighborhood with a
single mother and four siblings
and growing up in this neighborhood it
wasn't always easy
i've had too many friends who never
graduated high school
or that ended up sticking with the wrong
crowd or
friends that made just one mistake and
they sadly just haven't been able to
recover yet
i've had to overcome a lot of adversity
but thanks to the paramore kids zone
i found some incredible mentors that
have helped me out
and live up to my full potential and
helped me see more of the world than i
ever thought
i'd be able to see
but the truth is everyone deserves the
same opportunities that i have had
and while we are way past the point of
wondering
when is change going to come and if it
does come
will we see it in time
i know that it will come and a
presidential candidate who has a plan to
move this country forward
and lift everyone up is joe biden
[Music]
okay y'all can see me i'm young i'm a
part of generation z
and when i think about a platform and
the ideas that joe biden is running on i
feel hopeful
i know that i'm voting for is the best
opportunity to change our world
if you care about racial justice i need
you to get out and vote for joe biden
if you care about beating this pandemic
i need you to go out and vote for joe
biden
if you believe that health care is right
for everyone like joe does
i need you to get to the nearest voting
site and vote for joe biden
when you get out and vote please
recognize that you're not just voting
for yourself
when i vote i'm voting for the kids in
my neighborhood
who just want a fair shot at life i'm
voting to invest in our schools
and i'm voting to bring good paying jobs
into the neighborhoods around us
in this part of town i'm voting for
faces that i will never see
and names that i will never hear or know
orlando i love this community i love
us i believe in us we can change the
direction that this country is going on
every issue
that matters to us and that is the power
of a vote
so with just a week to election day
i need you to make a plan to vote early
now
this isn't one of those assignments that
i'm gonna turn in last minute
i know my plan to vote tomorrow when i'm
back in gainesville
i'll be voting early yes an assignment
done
early for joe biden and the right
student unions early voting site
and you better believe i'm bringing my
friends with me the whole squad
period
i don't know if i will ever live through
an election as important as this one
so orlando i want you to listen
carefully to our next speaker
this is a man who has inspired me to
believe in myself
and to have dreams and then dream bigger
than those dreams he's got a great
spotify playlist that i suggest y'all
check out and he's always had our back
while i was too young to vote for him
way back in the day
i'm proud to be voting for his vice
president orlando please welcome the
44th president of the united states
barack obama
[Music]
oh this is a good looking crowd here
thank you so much can everybody please
give lordan
a big round of applause for that great
introduction
what an outstanding young man
now it is good to be back here
in florida i don't know if we've got any
uh
tampa bay rays fans here in orlando
big game tonight it's do or die
time now the last time the rays
were in the world series in 2008
florida sent me to the white house
[Music]
[Applause]
now the rates fell just a bit short then
but here in florida
democrats felt a little bit short in
2016 also
over the next couple of weeks florida
you've got the chance
to fix two mistakes you've got the
chance to set
two things right you can bring a world
series championship to the sunshine
state
and you can send joe biden and kamala
harris to the white house
[Music]
we got one week orlando
one week c-sep waiter one week
until the most important election of our
lifetimes
and you don't have to wait until next
tuesday to cast your ballot you've got
two ways to vote right now
number one you can vote early in person
right now
number two you can vote from home with a
mail-in ballot
do not don't wait put it in the mail or
drop it off at a dropbox location today
don't take any chances just
get it done just go
just go to iwillvote.com
to find out where you can early vote in
person
or drop off your ballot if you've
already voted
how many of you have already voted
if you've already voted then your job is
to go help your friends and family
make a plan to vote because this
election
requires every single one of us and what
we do this week will matter for decades
to come
now i've sat in the oval office
with both of the men who were running
for president
and just in case you couldn't tell
they're very different people
i didn't think that donald trump would
embrace my vision or my policies
but i did hope for the country's sake
that he might show some
interest in taking the job seriously
but he didn't he hasn't shown any
interest in doing the work
or helping anybody but himself and his
friends
or treating the presidency as anything
more than a reality show
that can give him the attention that he
craves and he does crave attention
this week with all everything that's
happening you know what he brought up
he was fussing about the crowd size at
the inauguration again
saying his was bigger
[Music]
who who who is thinking about that right
now
nobody except him
but the rest of us have had to live with
the consequences
more than 225 000 people
in this country are dead more than a
hundred
thousand small businesses have closed
half a million jobs are gone
in florida alone think about that
and what what's his closing argument
that people are too focused on covet he
said this
at one of his rallies covet kobe coveted
he's complaining
he's jealous of kovid's media coverage
if he had been focused on covet from the
beginning
cases wouldn't be reaching new record
highs across the country this week
if we were focused on covet now the
white house wouldn't be having its
second
outbreak in a month the white house let
me say this
i lived in the white house for a while
you know
it's a controlled environment you can
take some preventive measures in the
white house to avoid getting sick
except this guy can't seem to do it he's
turned the white house into a hot zone
some of the places he holds rallies have
seen new spikes
right after elise town and over the
weekend his chief of staff said and i'm
quoting here i'm not making this
up his chief of staff
on a news program says
we're not going to control the pandemic
he just said this yes he did
and yes we noticed you're not going to
control
the pandemic listen winner is coming
they're waving the white flag of
surrender
florida we can't afford four more years
of this
that's why we've got to send joe biden
to the white house
[Applause]
because we cannot afford this kind of
incompetence and disinterest
12 years ago when i chose vice president
i didn't know joe all that well
we started in the senate together i
noticed by the way one of my great
friends
ben nelson at bill nelson c i
i haven't seen bill in a while so that's
why plus he's wearing a mask but
yep one of one of the great senators
from
from florida and joe and i served
together with
him and
you know i had a lot of friends in the
senate but
joe and i wasn't the closest person
but he and i came from different places
we came from different generations
but i quickly came to admire joe as a
man
who learned early to treat everybody he
meets with dignity and respect
and bill will testify this joe somebody
who lives by the words his parents
taught him
no one's better than you joe but you're
better than nobody
he believes everybody counts he believes
everybody's important
and that empathy that decency that
belief
in other people that's who joe is
and that's who he'll be i can tell you
the presidency doesn't change who you
are
it reveals who you are and joe time and
time again has shown himself
to be a man of principle and character
and he's going to be a great president
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
for eight years joe was the last one in
the room whenever i faced a big decision
he made me a better president and he's
got the character and the experience
to make us a better country and he and
kamala
are going to be in the fight not for
themselves but for every single one of
us
listen you've got a president right now
he wants full credit for
an economy that he inherited he wants
zero blame
for the pandemic he ignored
but you know what the job doesn't work
that way
you've got to be responsible 24 7.
you got to pay attention 24 7.
tweeting at the tv doesn't fix things
watching tv all day doesn't fix things
making stuff up doesn't fix things
you've got to have a plan if you want to
make people's lives better
you've got to put in the work if you
want to make people's lives better
and along with the experience to get
things done
joe biden has concrete plans and he's
got concrete policies
that will turn our vision of a better
fairer stronger country
into a reality
look here's the truth the pandemic would
have been challenging for any president
but this idea that somehow this white
house has done anything
but completely screw this thing up
is nonsense
[Applause]
south korea had its first case of kovid
at the same time the same week as the
united states
do you know that their per capita death
rate
is just 1.3
of what ours is think about that
statistic i've i've given this statistic
a couple times and
and people haven't really focused on it
the number of people in korea who have
died
of kovid per capita
is one at less than one and a half
percent what our death rate is
that's thousands and thousands of people
if we had been
as effective and responsible whose lives
would have been saved in this country
just across the border in canada the
death
rate per capita is 39 what ours here is
in the united states
we are the largest the wealthiest
most powerful country on earth and we
cannot somehow get a grip on this
because our government hasn't been doing
its job
last week
and last week when trump was asked if
he'd do anything
differently you know what he said he
said not much
not much really
not much you can't think of anything
that you might be doing differently like
maybe you shouldn't have gotten on tv
and suggested we might inject bleach
to cure kovid that's not something you
said you know maybe i shouldn't have
said that
not much think about how hard the
tourism industry
has been hit right here in orlando right
here in florida
you lost one spring training season
already and he can't think of
doing anything differently
joe takes this seriously
he knows the emotional toll on
grandparents when they can't see and hug
their grandkids
he's not going to screw up testing he's
not going to call scientists
idiots he's not going to host super
spreader events at the white house
and then take it on a tour all across
the country
joe will get this pandemic under control
with a plan
to make testing free and widely
available
[Music]
he's going to get a vaccine to every
american cost free
and he's going to make sure our
front-line heroes
never have to ask other countries for
the equipment that they need
to keep themselves safe
his plan will guarantee paid sickly for
workers and parents
affected by the pandemic he's going to
make sure that small businesses that
hold our communities together
and employ millions of americans can
reopen
safely and he understands that we're not
going to rebuild the economy
and put people back to work until we get
this pandemic
under control it's not that complicated
donald trump likes to claim he built
this economy but
i just want to remind you that america
created 1.5 million
more jobs in the last three years of the
obama
biden administration than in the first
three years of the trump
pence administration that's a fact
look it up
[Music]
and that was before trump could blame
the pandemic
he in fact inherited the longest streak
of job growth in american history
but just like everything else he
inherited
he screwed it up
[Music]
and the economic damage that he
inflicted by botching the pandemic
response
means he will be the first president
since herbert hoover
to actually lose jobs first president
since herbert hoover
back in the 30s that's a long time
people
that's almost 100 years ago
he loves to talk about black
unemployment look how low black
unemployment well
you know what unemployment was
really high when i came in and we
brought that um low and it kept on going
low
and he wants to take credit for it says
he's the best president for black folks
since abe lincoln
man now his advisors are out there
saying
including his son-in-law his son-in-law
says white folks have to want to be
successful
that's the problem
who are these folks what history books
do they read who do they talk to
don't read is that what is going on
black unemployment hit almost 17 during
the great recession
10 years ago and through a lot of hard
work joe biden and i helped get it down
and it kept on going down not because
trump did anything and then this year
because
they've screwed up the pandemic response
it soared back
up to above 17 here in florida
but it doesn't have to be that way
florida if you go out and vote
[Music]
yes we can listen the only people truly
better off
than they were four years ago are the
billionaires that got trump's tax cuts
in the meantime he has not been able to
manage
extending relief to millions of families
who can't pay the rent right now can't
put food on the table right now
got no plan to reopen schools that need
reopening
or protecting teachers in the process
you know i don't understand how it is
that he cannot
organize republicans in congress to do
the right thing
and it's not like it's his money that
we're asking to pay because he doesn't
pay taxes
barely pays income taxes
we know he's got a secret chinese bank
account so he's
he he may be paying taxes to the chinese
but he's not paying taxes here
first year in the white house only paid
750
in taxes in federal income taxes
750 can you imagine that
i mean teachers pay more than that
you know social workers pay more than
that in texas
huh soldiers
folks folks in uniform pay more in taxes
than that
so how are you living large and you're
not willing to
to do the right thing to make sure that
we're able to pay for quality schools
for our kids
to provide veterans benefits for those
who've earned them
joe biden has a plan to create 10
million good
clean energy jobs right here in america
it's part of his plan to protect florida
from climate change
and secure environmental justice and
he's going to pay for it
by rolling back those tax cuts to
[Music]
[Applause]
billionaires
[Music]
and the thing is joe doesn't just want
to get back to where we were
he finally wants to make some long
overdue changes so that our economy
actually makes life a little easier
for everybody the waitress trying to
raise a kid on her own
the student trying to figure out how to
pay for next semester's classes
the shift worker who's worried about
maybe being laid off
the cancer survivor who's worried that
her pre-existing conditions
might prevent her from being able to get
coverage
and speaking of health care by the way
you may have noticed republicans love
saying right before an election
how they're going to protect people who
have pre-existing conditions
have you noticed that well you know what
joe and i
actually protected them 10 years ago
with
the affordable care act
and you know those same republicans who
say they're going to protect them
somehow they have tried to repeal or
undermine
the affordable care act more than 60
times
and each time they try to repeal it they
say oh we've got a great replacement
it's coming it's
everybody's a little young here but you
you guys remember papa
remember that guy who always needed to
borrow some money for a hamburger
they said don't worry i'm going to be
paying you back sometime soon
that's like republicans with health care
they always say it's coming soon
we're going to be paying you back with a
great replacement plan
but that new that two weeks has been
10 years coming now for the last 10
years every two weeks they say we're
gonna have a great healthcare plan
you know where it is because i don't
the reason they don't have a plan
is because a plan doesn't exist they've
never had one
they've instead attacked the affordable
care act at every turn
driving up costs driving up the
uninsured
now they're trying to get the supreme
court to take away your health care
right now as quickly as they can in the
middle of a pandemic
with nothing but empty promises to take
its place
think about what that would do to
families right here in florida
florida has the highest enrollment
under the affordable care act of any
state in america
last week trump flat out said he hopes
the supreme court
takes your health insurance away set it
out loud
don't boo vote
and last night he installed the supreme
court justice who he hopes
will help him do it don't boo
vote florida this is serious
and joe and kamala will protect your
health care
they will expand medicare they'll make
insurance
more affordable for everybody
because joe knows that a president's
first job is to keep us safe
from all threats foreign domestic
and microscopic
when the daily intelligence briefings
flash warning lights about a virus
the president can't ignore it can't be
too lazy to read the briefing
when russia puts bounties on the heads
of our soldiers in afghanistan
the commander-in-chief can't be m.i.a
missing in action
joe biden would never call the men and
women of our military suckers
or losers because they're willing to
sacrifice their lives
on behalf of the american people
[Music]
joe biden understands those troops are
somebody's kids
somebody's dad somebody's mom somebody's
husband somebody's wife
somebody's father or mother
and joe biden understands that there is
glory and goodness in being willing to
sacrifice on behalf of others
something that apparently this
administration
just doesn't comprehend
our current president he whines that 60
minutes is too tough
you think he's going to stand up to
dictators he thinks leslie stalls a
bully
just yesterday just yesterday
he said that putin of russia
she of china and kim jong-un of north
korea
want him to win we know
we know because you've been giving them
whatever you want
for the last four years of course they
want you to win
that's not a good thing you shouldn't
brag about the fact that some of our
greatest adversaries
think they'd be better off with you in
office of course they do
what does that say about you
i mean think about that why are you
bragging about that
come on and that doesn't make any sense
joe biden wouldn't coddle dictators
he'll promote
human rights around the world including
in cuba
joe will restore our battered standing
around the world
because he knows our true strength comes
from setting an example that the world
wants to follow
a nation that stands with democracy not
dictators
a nation that can inspire and mobilize
others to overcome
threats like climate change and
terrorism and poverty and disease
and here's one other thing joan kamala
when they are in office they're not
going to have you're not going to have
to think about them every single day
you're not going to have to worry about
what crazy things they're going to say
what they're going to tweet they're just
gonna be too busy doing the work
[Applause]
it just won't be so exhausting
you'll be able to go about your lives
knowing that the president's
not going to retweet conspiracy theories
about
secret cabals running the world
or suggest i mean listen
our president of the united states
retweeted a a post
that claimed that the navy seals didn't
actually kill bin laden
think about that and we act like
okay it's not okay
we're not gonna have a president when
joe biden's in office
that goes out of his way to insult
people just because they don't support
him
he'll be a president for all people
including people who didn't vote for him
because he knows that's the job of being
president
[Music]
i i mean we've gotten so numb to what is
bizarre behavior we have a president
right now
who lies multiple times a day
and this is not my claim i even fox news
sometimes says well what he says isn't
really true he didn't mean it
it's not normal behavior we wouldn't
tolerate it from a co-worker
we won't tolerate it from a football
coach we wouldn't tolerate it from
a a high school principal we
we i mean we might have to put up with
it if it was a family member but
we talk about them afterwards
even florida man wouldn't be doing some
of this stuff
why would we accept it from president of
the united states
and you know what i i mean sometimes
it's almost too
easy to make fun of it but it's serious
there are consequences to his actions if
he was just on jerry springer or
something
you know you'd say well but
but this is this is the most powerful
office on earth
and when people see the president doing
things like that
it emboldens other people to be mean and
cruel
and divisive and racist
and it frays the fabric of our lives
it affects the way our children see
things when we tell
our children to tell the truth and then
we have
the person in the highest office in the
land who doesn't seem capable of doing
so
that undermines our society
it affects the way our families get
along it affects the way the world looks
at america and it distracts from the
truly destructive actions
that his cronies are doing
all across the government as we speak
actions that affect your lives
you've got the environmental protection
agency that's supposed to protect
our air and our water it's run by an
energy lobbyist
that gives polluters free reign to dump
unlimited poison into our air in our
water
it's not right it ain't right
the labor department that's supposed to
protect workers
it's run by a corporate lobbyist who's
declared war on workers
trying to gut protections to keep
essential folks
safe during a pandemic making it easier
for big corporations
to steal their wages the interior
department
that's supposed to protect our public
lands
our wilderness the everglades it's run
by an oil lobbyist
who's just fine with selling them to the
highest bidder
you've got an education department run
by a billionaire
who has got gutted rules designed to
protect
students from getting ripped off by
for-profit colleges
and that is stiff-arming students
looking for loan relief in the middle of
an economic collapse
you've got the person who runs medicaid
trying
not to get more people on the medicaid
so they've got better health care but to
kick more people off of medicaid
come on it ain't right
so what are you going to do about it you
got a boat
you've got to vote
when joe and kamala when joe and kamala
are in charge
they're not going to surround themselves
with hacks and lobbyists
they're going to surround themselves
with qualified public servants
who actually are serious about doing
their job
who are looking out for you for your job
your family your health your communities
your planet
and that more than anything is what
separates them from their opponents
they actually care about you they
actually care about every american
and they're going to be fighting on your
behalf every single day
they're not going to get everything
right every time
they're not gonna solve every problem
right away but they're gonna be
working on it every single day to see
how can i make sure
this little brand new baby right here
is inheriting a better world
that's what they care about
i will say that i miss kissing babies
during
pandemic i can't do it but
look at that little bundle right there
brand new
it's got the new baby smell
congratulations
but but joe and kamala they care deeply
about people and they care about
our democracy they believe that in a
democracy the right to vote is sacred
we shouldn't be making people wait in
line for hours
we should be making it easier for
everybody to vote not harder
[Music]
they believe that no one especially the
president
is above the law they understand the
protest
isn't un-american this country was
founded on protesting against injustice
[Music]
and we don't threaten to throw our
political opponents
in jail just because we disagree with
them that's what happens in
dictatorships it doesn't happen in the
united states of america
[Applause]
[Music]
joe and calmly understand that our
ability to work together to solve big
problems like the pandemic
depends on more than just photo ops it
depends on
applying facts and logic and science
and not making things up not flooding
the internet with misinformation these
should not be
republican or democratic values
they're what we grew up learning from
our parents and our grandparents
they're not white or black or hispanic
or asian or native american values
they're supposed to be american values
and we have to reclaim them right now
and how are we going to do that
by voting we've got to turn out like
never before orlando
we have to leave no doubt
we can't be complacent we were
complacent last time
folks got a little lazy folks took
things for granted
and look what happened not this time
not in this election i understand
there's some americans
who get frustrated by government they
feel like oh it doesn't make enough of
a difference my vote won't make a
difference listen
the government's not perfect it's not
going to solve every problem
but a good government can make things
better
things were better when i left office
than when i started
they weren't perfect but they were
better
a president shouldn't make things worse
a president by himself can't solve every
challenge facing our economy
but if we elect a president who cares
and we elect a house and a senate and a
state house in the state senate
that are focused on working people and
getting you the help you need
it can make a difference
[Applause]
a president by himself can't eliminate
all racial bias in our criminal justice
system
but if we elect district attorneys and
states attorneys and sheriffs
and police chiefs focused on equality
and justice
it can make things better
and that's what voting is about not
making things perfect but making them
better
it's about putting us on track so that a
generation from now we can look back and
say
hey things started getting better it's
about using the power we have and
pulling it together
to make sure that we have a government
that's more concerned
more responsive more focused on you
and you know what when i hear people say
well i don't know i voted last time
things didn't change as much as i
thought listen
we've never come close to seeing what it
would be like if everybody voted
in 2008 that was the highest voting
rate in modern presidential history you
know what
we only got to 61
that means 39 of the folks didn't vote
who were eligible to vote what would
happen if suddenly
we started getting 70 voting rates
[Music]
[Applause]
what what would happen if we got 60 70
of the people voting instead of 55
percent of people voting
the country would be transformed imagine
imagine january 20 and we swear in a
president and a vice president
who have a plan to deal with this
pandemic effectively
who believe in science we have a plan to
protect this planet
for our children who care about working
americans
who have a plan to help you start
getting ahead who believe in racial
equality
we're willing to do the work to bring us
closer to the ideal
that no matter what you look like where
you come from who you love how much
money you got
you can make it here in america you'll
be treated
with respect and dignity and justice
here in america
imagine a president when puerto rico
gets hit by a hurricane
doesn't respond just by throwing paper
towels
but says those are americans and we've
got to make sure that we get in
the help they need as quickly
as possible that's what you should
expect from a president
and if you're not getting that then you
have to go out there and vote
to make it happen
[Applause]
[Music]
all of that is possible all of that is
within our reach
for all the times these past four years
when we've seen our worst impulses
revealed
the good news is we've also seen our
best impulses revealed
we've seen folks of every age and
background pack city centers
in town squares so that families
wouldn't be separated
i've got a friend jose andres great
restaurateur
took it upon himself went down to puerto
rico after the hurricane
organized thousands of meals just on his
own because he was seeing that
the response wasn't quick enough just
did it on his own
that is america
we saw we saw people out on the streets
saying we're not going to have our
classrooms shut up anymore
we've seen people activated to make sure
our kids don't grow up
on an uninhabitable planet we've seen
health care workers
so many of them all across the country
risk their lives
every single day just to save
somebody else's loved ones
we've seen people contribute and
volunteer to neighbors
that have been hit hard we've seen
americans of all races joining together
to declare
in the face of injustice and brutality
at the hands of the state
that black lives matter no more but no
less
so that no child in this country should
feel the continuing sting of racism
that's true in orlando it's true in
florida it's true all across this
country
america is a good and decent place
but we've just seen so much noise and
nonsense
and distortion and sometimes it's hard
for us to remember
but orlando i'm asking you to remember
what this country can be
what it should be what it must be i am
asking you to believe in joe's ability
to lead this country out of these dark
times to help us build it back better
don't abandon those who are hurting
right now
we can't abandon the kids who aren't
getting the education they need right
now
we can't abandon all those young people
who are out on the streets who inspired
us we got to channel their activism into
action
we can't just dream for a better future
we got to fight for a better
future we gotta out hustle the other
side
we've got to vote like never before
and leave no doubt so make a plan
vote as early as you can grab your
friends and your family
get them to vote all the way up and down
the ticket and if we pour
all our efforts into this final week
if we vote like never before
then we will elect joe biden president
of the united states we'll elect kamala
harris vice president of the united
states
we will establish once again
what this country stands for what our
values are
who we are as a people let's get to work
florida
let's bring it home
[Music]
i love you orlando i love you florida
punk if you're fired up
honk if you're ready to go are you fired
up
are you ready to go i'm fired up
let's go do this thing let's bring it
home
[Music]
dreams
[Music]
[Music]
here i'll stand by
[Music]
behind your sorrows
[Music]
[Music]
these wheels
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this